Це терористи. Вони багато зарізали шиїтів.
Це шиїти, які кажуть: будь ласка, ми бідні люди, не треба нас вбивати.
А це військові армії Афганістану, їх вбили.
А це їхні діти. Вони просили відпустити їхнього батька.
Зброю, якою нам Америка допомагала, таліби хочуть продати Пакистану...
Гхулам Сакхі, Наім та Азім. Усі вони біженці з Афганістану
і вже кілька років живуть в Україні.
Вони пильно стежать за останніми новинами з батьківщини.
В них там залишилися родичі, друзі, знайомі…
Розумієте, тато, мамо, сестра - всі там.
Я так за них переживаю!.. Я так нервую, що останнім часом навіть починаю
щось забувати, навіть втрачаю свідомість.
Останнім часом такий стан. Я дуже сильно переймаюся за своїх рідних.
Наім Мохаммад - голова афганської общини в Україні,
його телефон не змовкає. Біженці, які мешкають в Україні,
благають домовитися з посольством України в Таджикистані,
аби ті пустили їхніх рідних в літак до України.
Проте Мохаммад мало що може зробити.
Я телефоную послу, питаю: "Пане посол, яких людей можна евакуювати?"
Він відповідає: "Громадян України, які можуть взяти членів своєї родини -
дружину, дітей".
Там в аеропорту вже стільки людей, що навіть ті, що з легальними документами,
не можуть потрапити.
33-ти річний Азім у розпачі від того, що ніяк не може допомогти своїм рідним.
Його дружина і діти, на щастя, в Україні, але не мають ані документів,
ані дозволу на роботу. Щоб прогодувати родину, Азім хапається за будь-що,
часто за копійки. Чоловік втік з Афганістану в 2014 році.
Таліби погрожували його вбити, викрали брата, вимагаючи від Азіма інформацію,
адже він працював айтішником в адміністрації тодішнього афганського президента.
Проте українська міграційна служба вважає, що Азіма з родиною
слід депортувати до Афганістану,
оскільки дозвіл на перебування в країні йому не подовжили.
Кожні три місяці дають довідку, подовжують.
Є такі довідки, що подовжують на шість місяців, на рік.
У нас на три місяці. Нещодавно дружина зайшла, щоб подовжити документи,
так вони нам відмовили.
У дружини вже три відмови, у мене дві. Ми подали до суду, оскаржуємо.
Їй сказали: або їдьте до своєї крани, або якщо тут хочете залишитися,
то заново робіть усі документи.
Немає чіткої процедури легалізації біженців в Україні.
Державні служби не хочуть давати афганцям нормальні документи,
каже Гхулам Сакхі. Колись в Афганістані він був успішним
на міжнародні арені спортсменом з вільної боротьби.
Тепер в Україні працює то вантажником, то продавцем, то ще кимось.
В Україні він вже майже 10 років, але й досі з українських документів -
лише ось цей папірець - довідка про те, що особа звернулася по захист.
За це час він одружився з українкою, але навіть це не допомогло йому
отримати статус біженця чи хоча б офіційний дозвіл
на проживання в Україні.
Ось, мені поставили депортацію.
І забрали довідку в міграційній службі.
Тепер я маю виїхати спочатку до Афганістану, потім до Таджикистану
в посольство України і там отримати візу. Чесно кажучи, це нереально.
Там мафія скрізь сидить, і без грошей нікому нічого не дають.
Враховуючи те, що в Афганістані почалася війна, свою візу Ді Гхулам Сакхі,
тепер, мабуть, вже так і не отримає. Він також не хоче зв’язуватися
із різними незаконними схемами легалізації іноземців в Україні, які коштують
від трьох до семи тисяч доларів.
Через відсутність документів, його будь-якої миті може зупинити поліція і оштрафувати.
На підставі довідок з міграційної служби їх офіційно не беруть на роботу.
І якщо вони, приміром, працюють на ринках, то приїжджають
співробітники поліції, їх забирають, штрафують.
Я потім як голова громади йду в поліцію.
Там кажуть, що вони порушили закон. Я кажу, що я розумію,
що це порушення, але що ж їм робити? Держава нічого не дає.
Їм же треба якось жити, вони ж не можуть повітрям харчуватися!
У такій ситуації опиняються навіть ті афганці, які народилися в Україні.
Як 20-ти річний Нардін Накшбанді.
Я стикався з тим, що мене тут кілька разів затримували.
Вони спілкуються з нами не як з людьми, а ніби з якимось тваринами…
Кинули в машину, забрали телефон, вимагали гроші.
Мовляв, або ми тебе відпускаємо, або їдеш з нами.
Я гроші не дав, і мене відвезли в міграційну службу,
тримали з 11-тої вечора до 5-тої ранку і винесли рішення про депортацію.
Сказали залишити Україну.
Юнак вважає це беззаконністю. Адже він ніколи не був в Афганістані.
Крім того, він має свідоцтво про народження в Україні, закінчив
українську школу, має навіть власний ідентифікаційний код.
Більше того, він народився в родині колишнього військового,
який охороняв президента Афганістана
і вимушений був тікати з країни в 1996-тому році.
Батько Нардіна має документи - статус біженця. Але його синові
вперто не видають український паспорт.
Нардін займається кікбоксингом,
мав амбіції стати успішним спортсменом, поступити в інститут фізкультури.
Проте всі ці мрії вщент розбили чиновники.
Я міг потрапити в збірну країни, але не потрапив, бо в мене немає документів.
Паспорт не зробили, кажуть, що я щось там не підтвердив у 18-ть років.
І що мені робити, не кажуть.
Нардін написав листа президенту Зеленському. Адвокат хлопця намагається
вибити йому паспорт. Проте Україну навряд чи можна вважати країною,
яка хоче приймати у себе біженців, легалізувати їхніх дітей,
кажуть експерти організації Free Belarus Centre  "Фрі Бєларус Сентер",
які вирішують схожі проблеми з документами для біженців з Білорусі.
В Україні дуже непросте міграційне законодавство.
Дуже сувора міграційна служба.
Багато хто з білорусів були б щасливі тут залишитися і працювати,
але вимушені їхати далі, тому що легалізуватися тут дуже складно.
І отримати статус біженця теж дуже і дуже складно.
В УВКБ ООН вже кілька років нарікають, що в Україні низький рівень
кількості позитивних рішень за заявами про надання захисту або про статус біженця.
За даними організації, в Україні нині перебуває понад шість з половиною тисяч
шукачів притулку, які очікують на розгляд свого клопотання міграційною службою або судом.
Але лише близько ста з них на рік отримують позитивні рішення,
іншим - відмовляють. Юристи Free Belarus Centre "Фрі Бєларус Сентр" вважають,
що міграційне законодавство України треба лібералізувати.
Євросоюз вже заявив про готовність переглянути процедуру надання статусу біженця
у зв’язку із ситуацією в Афганістані.
У своєму Твіттері заступник голови Єврокомісії Маргарітіс Схінас зазначив,
що необхідно якнайшвидше переглянути міграційні правила
та умови надання притулку для тих, хто втікає від режиму талібів.
За підрахунками афганської громади, ще до кризи в серпні цього року в Україну
переїхали близько 5000 п'яти тисяч афганців.
Майже половина з них живе роками без документів.
Голова організації не розуміє, як Україна збирається виконувати
свої зобов'язання, приймаючи далі біженців з Афганістану,
коли закони працюють погано, житла для біженців немає,
а державна фінансова виплата становить кілька десятків гривень.
Я, чесно кажучи, не знаю, на що люди розраховують.
Кажуть, що Україна хоче прийняти 2000 біженців з Афганістану.
В нас і так тут знаходиться майже 2000 людей без документів.
І земляки просять, якщо Україна не може надати нам притулок,
то хай відправляє нас в треті країни.
Навряд чи нові або старі біженці з Афганістану зможуть потрапити в третю країну.
Адже Україна має зобов’язання, зокрема перед ЄС, приймати у себе біженців.
Афганці, які живуть в Україні, розуміють, що в Афганістані ситуація
буде лише погіршуватися, і вони, мабуть, назавжди залишаться в Україні.
Треба всім країнам відкривати свою душу і серце афганцям.
Я не можу сказати, що всі афганці добрі люди.
Але треба біженцям допомагати.
І тут багато людей таких, як я.
Є люди, які 15-18 років живуть без документів.
Ми більше нічого не хочемо від держави,
їсти нам не треба давати.
Тільки дайте нам нормальні документи, щоб ми могли працювати і платити податки.
За два роки біженці з Афганістану подали до Офісу президента
кілька сотень скарг. Також приблизно 200 заяв про надання громадянства України.
Поки помітних змін немає, скаржиться голова афганської громади.
Афганці сподіваються на діалог з українською владою,
який та обіцяє розпочати у вересні.